detail a terrorist attacks in Paris have
shaken and shocked the Western world
what can we what must we now do in
Europe and in Germany questions for
Germany's Justice Minister Heiko Maas he
is convinced that one thing must not be
allowed to happen that we left the
terrorists destroy our way of life the
social democrat politician is our guest
this week happy to como the cordial
welcome to you as well our DW viewers my
name is Alexandre phenomen hamas mr.
mosque will we really be able to
continue living as before considering
the acute threats at home mandus
misfortune you will have to be able to
or else the terrorists will have won
because the attacks in Paris were
attacks on all of us and especially on
our way of life our open society with
freedom of expression freedom of
religion and respect intolerance for
each other we can't let them take that
away from us and that's why it's
important to hold tight to our values
and not to let our way of life be
destroyed because that's the terrors
real target I take an example the
international soccer match between
Germany and the Netherlands last Tuesday
initially it was said that the game
should take place also as a sign of
solidarity with France but then there
was an indication apparently one that
had to be taken seriously of a planned
attack and the game was called off on
short notice so in this case the
terrorists have won haven't they this
kind of hit yes and that could happen
again in the future
I thought the German Football League was
right to initially plan to go ahead with
the match but in the future for all big
events we'll have to scrutinize whether
the security situation in the run-up to
the game allows us to say the risk and
there is always a risk is not so great
not so great that we have to fear the
loss of human life
but in this case especially in the last
few hours before the match developments
were so dramatic with such specific
indications of plans for an attack
during the game that we decided to
cancel this match otherwise we would
have been wanting Li endangering
people's lives in the fog revisions and
you yourself were looking forward to
attending this match when did you learn
that there was such a concrete danger
that you couldn't enter the stadium
that's a huge study under love it is now
with us in the course of the afternoon
we had indications and they were
verified and unfortunately not until
after 6:00 p.m. did the last report come
in to the information we already had did
indeed come from reliable sources and
then we responded very quickly and
cancelled the match were you afraid no
to be honest I wasn't afraid but maybe
that was because we were so busy
preparing an important decision
but on Friday when the attacks were
staged in Paris my brother and his wife
were in a Paris restaurant not far from
the ones that were targeted
so I worried about them that's when you
see how close this terrorism has come
sometimes it's just a matter of luck
that you weren't in the wrong restaurant
um quick finish as disadvantage
impression of that's the longer that's
not so how was a double burger did your
family discuss the attacks at home you
have two sons the older one is 13 in an
interview you said he's very interested
in what goes on in the world and that he
even has a news app did you talk with
him or maybe with both sons about what
happened in Paris both hideth yeah
didn't we did I'm [ __ ] because they
asked whether it was safe for them to
play soccer on the soccer pitch and
whether we were going to stop going to
restaurants and it's not so easy to
answer that I can kids ask very simple
honest questions and it's not always
easy to find an appropriate answer but I
think the only thing that helps is to
talk about these things to calm them
down make it clear that would
doing everything we can to keep
something like that from happening here
that's but once a fascination keshite
what is the German government doing to
protect people in Germany from attacks
yeah I met some so that language is in
the aftermath of Paris we've
substantially increased security and
police presence at critical points train
stations airports and other places where
lots of people come together the
individuals in Germany we think closing
danger who were already under
observation by our intelligence agencies
are now under even more intense
surveillance in some cases we'll have to
go after one or another of them in
recent months we've also tightened the
loss octave is that solenoid leash for
shaft in particular these so-called
foreign fighters who go from here to
Syria to fight for is in the battles and
then come back at some point
radicalized are a real risk when they
return yet it's just easy cause in
transit that's all
so we've now made leaving for serious
illegal which means we can stop them
from going there from Dean get they are
a great danger and have to be especially
closely watched and if we know that one
of them is planning on going or is
returning the security agencies have to
intervene and arrest such people and
take them off the streets it's justice
minister you tightened the
anti-terrorism laws in Germany after the
attack on Charlie Hebdo but there's been
criticism from security experts that it
makes no sense to make new laws or
tighten them they say it makes more
sense to invest more in police forces so
that those who you think pose a danger
can in fact be observed so do the
anti-terrorism laws you've tightened up
make Germany safer Mukilteo transitions
are just nuts Nick's some say these laws
are useless some say they don't go far
enough we think that we've taken a
proven middle path
Phaneuf ding wittle Vica for now our
orientation has been to change the law
only when we're convinced it will be
abuse alternately we must not give
people the impression that changing a
law already makes Germany safer it
really depends on how we use our
existing personnel and organization to
combat the dangers and that's why we
have 3000 live jobs with the federal
police and hundreds of new positions
with the intelligence services we have
an overall concept and I'm sure that
that will provide greater security for
Germany the shadows I saw a torch lent
me a session ID playing with new
measures and suggestions are under
discussion after the Paris attacks can
we go through them briefly for example
there's the suggestion to give the
secret intelligence services more powers
and more personnel are you for or
against this night as a mere peasant
negative well we have more personnel now
for the intelligence services and their
powers are extensive enough you could
actually get the impression that if
intelligence agencies concentrated less
on spying on our friends and use their
existing capacities better in dealing
with the terrorists that the game would
be half won that's why we're reforming
laws governing the federal intelligence
service lead be any yes or no federal
intelligence service law avoid attending
our we want to give the intelligence
services the equipment and personnel
they require because we know that
they're essential in combating
international terrorists but we also
want proper parliamentary control over
them so they don't take on a life of
their own and that's how we're
reorganizing things right now this could
shoot October there's also discussion on
whether the security services should
have greater access to our personal data
across Europe I'd become
for example showed information on where
people fly be stored what do you think
so I fight indeed avram p.m. enough
analysis it might think that in the
foreseeable future in the next few
months we'll have a new arrangement
but that's because it's surely prudent
to know who is moving where within
Europe that's why I think that in the
future
this will be standardized across Europe
all citizens who control willpower fight
I not just get eager to have it justice
minister in the past you've always
expressed scepticism about such access
have you changed your mind
I have no and the discussions we're
still having I've always advocated not
letting it all get out of hand I think
we have to consider which gender should
be stored does everyone's data have to
be stored you know including on air
traffic within Europe or should the data
be stored for all of five years what a
shorter period suffice but I'm confident
that we'll find a reasonable system that
balances freedom and security when it
finds a good answer to God what given
that an affordable after the attacks in
Paris some politicians have called for
sealing the European Union's external
borders and making sure they're closed
what do you think about that there's
nothing that happens in that one yeah
that's like it I hope I as it didn't
hang it up commerce the Schengen treaty
stipulates that Europe's internal
borders ought to be permeable but the
outer borders should be made secure and
controllable we haven't done that
adequately in the past and that's why I
think we have some catching up to do
otherwise the individual EU states will
start closing off their internal borders
and if we start shutting ourselves off
from each other I think that would be a
setback for the idea of a unified Europe
but it is true that the external
boundaries have to be made more secure
than they have been in the past are you
afraid that is fighters could try to
enter Germany mixed in with refugees and
that this could change the debate about
refugee policy in Germany in thought
stance and on content other scripts I'd
kind of believe at the moment there's no
evidence that that's happening I'd be
very careful about connecting the two
because the refugees coming to us from
Syria are fleeing the same madman who
carried out the attacks in Paris namely
Islamic state their victims not
perpetrators and that's why we shouldn't
talk about whether these people are
alleged refugees in Germany it wasn't
refugees who carried out the attacks but
people who had lived among us all their
lives people we might have known but
would never have suspected could do
something like this Kenneth Howard and
Angela and knowing this means that a
responsible discussion would not mix up
the issues of terrorism and refugees I
think that is downright irresponsible
besides all statistic fit one find for
delicious TV interviews at the end of
every DW interview we have our three
unfinished sentences and I'd like you to
complete these sentences absolute
insecurity is unfortunately impossible
nowadays vineeth destiny the next time I
enter a stadium I won't go alone but
together with my children and I'll act
the same as I always have
for my Niki for my children I wanted
Germany Duss it is open to the world
intolerant and in which people who live
here show the greatest possible respect
for each other that's biggish giggling
mr. Moss thank you very much